[Music]
here lies
arthur king who was and king
who will be so reads the inscription
on king arthur's gravestone in thomas
mallory's
le morte d'artur writing in the 15th
century
mallory couldn't have known how
prophetic this inscription would turn
out to be
king arthur has risen again and again in
our collective imagination
along with his retinue of knights
guinevere
the round table camelot and of course
excalibur but where do these stories
come from
and is there any truth to them king
arthur
as we know him is a creation of the
later middle ages
but his legend actually has its roots in
celtic poetry
from an earlier time the saxon invasions
of britain
after the romans left britain in 410
ce saxon invaders from what's now
germany and denmark quickly capitalized
on the vulnerability
of the abandoned territory the
inhabitants of britain
fought fiercely against the invaders
through several centuries of turmoil
there are hardly any written records
from this time so it's difficult to
reconstruct an accurate history
however surviving poetry from the era
gives us some clues
one of the poems the gododin contains
the very first reference to arthur
though arthur himself doesn't actually
appear in it
it says a different warrior named
guardar
was skilled at slaying his enemies but
was no arthur
that's not much to go on but whoever
this arthur was
he must have been the gold standard of
warriors
whether he ruled anyone or even lived at
all is unfortunately less clear
despite this uncertainty references to
arthur
caught the attention of an aspiring
historian hundreds of years later
in 1130 jeffrey of monmouth
was a lowly cleric with grand ambitions
using celtic and latin sources he spent
years creating a lengthy chronicle
titled the history of the kings of
britain
the centerpiece of this tome was king
arthur
history is a generous term for jeffrey's
account
writing 600 years after the saxon
invasions he cobbled together fragments
of myth and poetry to compensate for the
almost complete lack of official records
a few of his sources contained mentions
of arthur and some others were realistic
accounts of battles and places
but many featured mythic heroes fighting
long odds with the help of magical
swords and sorcery
jeffrey blended them all a magical sword
called californ
and a roman fortress called kellyanne
appeared in his source material
so jeffrey's arthur ruled from kellyanne
and wielded
caliburnus the latin translation of
calvra
jeffrey even added a wise counsellor
named merlin
based on the celtic bard murder to
arthur's story
if arthur did live he would likely have
been a military leader
but a castle-bound king better fit
jeffrey's regal
history jeffrey's chronicle got the
attention he had hoped for and was soon
translated from latin into french by the
poet ways
around 1155 ce wace added another
centerpiece of arthurian lore to
geoffrey's sword
castle and wizard the round table
he wrote that arthur had the table
constructed so that all the guests in
his court would be equally placed
none could boast that he had the highest
position at the table after reading
waste's translation
another french poet critian de troi
wrote a series of romances that
catapulted arthur's story to fame
he introduced tales of individual
knights like lancelot
and gawain and mixed elements of romance
in with the adventurous
he conceived arthur lancelot and
guinevere's love triangle
in addition to interpersonal intrigue he
also
introduced the holy grail
[Music]
probably based his grails powers on
magical objects
in celtic mythology he lived in the
middle of the crusades
and others imposed the preoccupations of
the time
on the grail casting it as a powerful
relic
from the crucifixion numerous
adaptations in french and other
languages followed from kretian's work
in the course of these retellings
kaelian became camelot
and caliburnus was re-christened
excalibur
in the 15th century sir thomas mallory
synthesized these stories
in le mot da tour the basis of many
modern accounts of king arthur
in the thousand years since arthur first
appeared in a celtic poem
his story has transformed over and over
to reflect the concerns of his
chroniclers
and their audiences and we're still
rewriting and adapting the legend today
whether or not the man ever lived loved
reigned or adventured
it's undeniable that the character has
achieved immortality
do you enjoy sorting fact from fiction
if so you're in the right place please
subscribe to our channel
and if you'd like to help support our
mission further consider making a small
monthly contribution
on patreon.com
[Music]
you